continuing in this awesome development
of do-it-yourself kits home of Po has
also created a doyour yourself monkey
fist kit which comes with your Kevlar
rope and your a device this is what goes
into the middle of the your your knot
and the whole thing tightens around it
so they've invented this as a sort of
safe and easy way to make a monkey fist
and then you've got some glue that makes
all secure in the end and of course your
tether um so you put all this together
and you can build your own monkey fists
now I've really been wanting to get this
video up and um because I already have
an awesome pair of fire pooy I've been
procrastinating on finishing the actual
assembly of the monkey fist and it does
take longer than the dragon staff the
dragon staff took me one minute and this
takes some more fiddling um but I wanted
to get this video up so um monkey fist
kits if you want a um a more affordable
alternative and you want to be really
connected to the you know the creation
of your very own firep um awesome way to
go um yeah and just points for
cleverness I
[Music]
say